back at Stanford when I say back at
Stanford I didn't study here in fact I
had do not have an MBA as you'll spot
very quickly but I had been here before
and it really is just a great place I
also had the chance of spending the
weekend here and to get to know some of
you so to those of you that I've had the
chance to meet over the weekend could I
just say thank you you've give me a
great welcome give me a great feel for
the place I have to say I think you guys
really really are lucky to get to spend
two years here now what I'd like to do
with you this morning is to give you
some perspectives on leadership that's
the topic you've been talked out a lot
I'm sure and I hope you thought about a
lot about but I want to give you some
perspectives and I chose the word
perspectives quite deliberately I'm not
going to talk about my personal
leadership story it'll be a very very
short presentation indeed if I did but I
want to talk to you about what I've
observed in the many leaders or
purported leaders that I've worked with
over the last 35 years so this is
perspectives on leadership based on what
I seen and what I've heard not just in
business I've worked with people in the
not-for-profit sectors and the public
sector a little bit as well and also for
outside business well so it's really
some general thoughts on leadership and
what I hope to do what I hope to do is I
hope to give you some insights on what
it takes to be a good leader whether
that's in business or in your personal
life or whatever some insights on
leadership and as it's a business school
may be one or two things that you could
do to improve your own personal
leadership skills so that's my hope if
at least 20 percent if you leave is
saying huh I could do do something with
that that would be really really great
I'll talk about 25 minutes and then I'll
throw it open to Q&A anyone to ask about
what I said well I didn't say about the
world at large please just prepare your
questions that I'd be thrilled to have
the chance to get get involved in that
now let me before I start let me just
provide a few comments that I think
frame the topic of leadership before I
get into what I think that makes for a
great leader just some contextual
comments
firstly leadership is a non-hierarchical
concept in my view it's a
non-hierarchical concept people often
confuse positions of leadership with the
exercise of leadership there are many
people who are leaders who in my view
are not leaders at all they happen to be
in leadership positions there are many
people who are not in positions of
leadership who exercise leadership try
and think of it as a non hierarchical
concept it's independent of a position
there are some organizations that
recognize it the military is very very
good at recognizing this you they know
that a sergeant or a platoon leader is a
leader organizations tend to be less
good they assume that the more seen you
are the better the leader you are and it
is not true so when I know this called
the view from the top and Dean perhaps
have a suggestion from you I think that
leadership needs to be viewed from the
bottom from the middle and the top so
maybe the next course you do have view
from the bottom as a thought I I jest
but I think it's important you look at
leadership through many many lenses and
good organizations people are leaders at
all levels including secretaries right
up to the Chairman so it's a non
hierarchical concept there are many CEOs
and chairmen I've worked with that in my
view an optically good leaders and there
many people never recognize as good
leaders who are very good leaders and
I'd like to focus on what I think are
the good leaders so that's point number
one by way of context non hierarchical
second point I'd like to make is that
leadership is a multi-faceted concept it
is it can be defined in a number of
different ways most people think about
business leaders or military leaders but
just step back and think you can be a
ring leader you could be a gang leader
you can be a thought leader you can be a
fashion leader these are all leaders
leadership and I one of the things I get
uncomfortable school is that leadership
is often channeled through a very narrow
prism but remember there are lots of
different types of leadership and it's
very important that they can be very
valuable to me one of the great balance
the last 20 years has been the emergence
of the geek as the lead
and to me it's a logical consequence of
the move to the knowledge economy as we
move to knowledge economy you're gonna
have a lot more geeks as leaders so I
think that numbers of different ones
that you think about leaders and
leadership don't just dismiss the geeky
nerdy guys in the corners not leaders
some of them I promise you will surpass
all of you as leaders same with fashion
same with socials so leadership is a
multi-faceted concept when you talk
about leadership I think it's very very
important talk about what sort of
leadership are you thinking about
so it's non hierarchical it's
multifaceted and then the final point
I'll make before I get into my views on
what defines a leadership as you step
back and think about it is it is
contextually driven now you're all being
told this about context but you cannot
look at leadership in the isolation of
the context that you're in if I focus on
the business world if you're leading a
company in the high-tech industry or the
food industry your challenge is
completely different if you're trying to
lead McKinsey or the Graduate School of
Business or a medical faculty or a
regiment your leadership task is
completely different if we're trying to
lead a group of Japanese people or
people from Brazil as opposed to a group
from Silicon Valley your leadership task
is completely different you have to
understand context to understand
leadership this can be true within the
same industry if you are working we live
with
we're in Silicon Valley a big high-tech
company leading a high-tech company
whose heritage is in Korea or Taiwan is
completely different from leading a
high-tech company whose heritage is in
Silicon Valley or Munich even though
they may be making exactly the same
product so context is all when you think
about leadership and I come unto what I
think that means for the development of
one's own leadership skills so some
framing comments about at least one
person's view on leadership is it's non
hierarchical it's multifaceted and it is
context driven
I have a view on leadership is that it
cannot be defined by characteristics
most of the books and most the talks
you'll get will tell you about what
great leaders are they're good listeners
they're authentic they're dynamic and my
view on that having watched the 30 years
is hmm maybe maybe I work with some
great leaders who listen accordingly in
fact most of the good leaders I work
with listen appalling me some are not
very authentic I'm not sure I quite
understand what authentic means but I
think they're not very authentic if I
got it right some people have no vision
at all and don't believe in it I talked
to one brilliant seer who reminded me of
the very very good point he said the
line between vision and a hallucination
is very small indeed and I don't like it
great leader great leader so I need
generalizations about leader
characteristics I personally think are
interesting but not very helpful and
they're also not very helpful you get
people telling you how to be great
leader and you say well I'm not like
that does that mean that you can't be a
great leader the answer's no it does not
you have to define it your own terms
around you and your organization so my
view is that leadership is best
explained by what leaders actually do
and remember I'm not talking to us about
business leaders it could be personal
leaders parents in some ways the leaders
think about that perhaps have more
influence over people who virtually
anyone I want to talk about what leaders
actually do and in a sense I'm trying to
define leadership from the perspective
of the followers to follow us sometimes
I think it's when you're trying to
define something look it's through a
different prism just like it's often
easier to explain success by looking at
mistakes sometimes it's easier to think
that leadership by terms of followership
and I think and this is my synthesis and
you may think it's rather sad commentary
on my last 30 years right when I look at
the effective leaders that I see I think
that they all they all whatever that
walk of life do five things they all do
five things I just like to go through
the five things that they do not that
they are what they say but they actually
do in the eyes of their followers
number one all leaders set a direction
all leaders Sattar direction it might be
a vision it might be a culture but they
set a direction they might write it down
they might have a big plan which has got
the Kinsey slides in it saying this is
our strategy it might be just
articulated it might be never said and
family businesses they're often never
said but there is a direction and if you
ask most people in the company they will
be able to tell you what that direction
is what the beliefs of the company are
all leaders do this they can do it a
number of different ways then get half
on technique focus on the direction you
might want to put strategy vision you
fill in the dots for yourselves but to
me I use the word direction people in
the organization know where that going
they may not like it they may not
approve of it they may disagree with it
but people in the organization know
where the company is going or where the
organization is going so one thing that
leaders do in my view is they set a
direction the second thing that leaders
do all leaders do in my view is that
they initiate stuff leaders don't just
manage the status quo
now sometimes initiating staff can be
stopping things happening some of the
worst stages of leadership personally
and in observation was in the.com boom
and bust when not enough filler stop
things that we knew were wrong happening
that's initiation going against a trend
could be initiative but usually leaders
start things I don't confuse this with
entrepreneurship it can be
entrepreneurship its initiating things
they initiate change they want to do
things in pursuit of that direction I
don't think as I look back on the
effective leaders that I've worked with
they order them have initiated things a
lot of not effective leaders have talked
about initiating things they talked
about change
beware of leaders that talked about
change all the time
this time all the time talking about it
and doing it often but real leaders
initiate stuff so initiation initiative
starting things innovate is part of that
is different than innovation we might
want to talk about that but they
initiate things so that is
characteristic number two is set
direction and then you initiate things
usually around that direction the third
thing that leaders do amongst always
emphasized this to MBA students because
typically very brilliant MBA facts are
bad at this
leaders sustain momentum around those
initiatives they stick with them this is
why you often really read books around
leaders or lectures on how to be a great
leader you hear the word tenacity
determination bullheadedness obstinacy
that's it the extreme of sticking with
it
but practical leaders I've worked with
that comes a point when absent this is
another fine line when obstinacy becomes
lunacy there is a point of that so and
as you've know a lot of very strong
leaders do go into the lunacy a phase of
obstinacy they stick with things and
typically something I observe that MBAs
are very bad at doing they say how that
didn't work I'll try something else this
is the danger of an entrepreneurial
mindset stick with things but
entrepreneurial leaders stick with
things too so sticking with things
sustaining momentum including through
bad times I think is a really really
important part of leadership and you all
know even observation will tell you that
always things are gonna go wrong and the
real leaders they stick with it the wise
ones know when to stop we can talk about
that but in the end the stearic turistic
of leadership is sticking with things
direction initiative sticking with it
the fourth thing that all leaders do in
some form another in my view is that
they motivate others to do what they
want them to do they motivate people
I used to say inspire and then I realize
from observation as due to my own value
judgment on motivation I happen to think
that many of you the being inspired is
an incredible form of motivation
had to conclude that actually it's not
true to say that leaders or leaders
inspire there a number of techniques of
motivation we've got nine through with
inspiration at all
greed is one some leaders are very
effective at using greed as a motivator
fear it is another manipulation is
another encouragement is another there
are various techniques to motivation
it's quite important for you not to
impose your own moral values at this
stage on what works the point I'm making
is that great leaders motivate people to
do things and the really great one thing
what will motivate those people to do it
how you harness those motivations and
you get them consistent with a value set
of a company is a huge issue in its own
right so you can't just say I know Bill
money's his thing argument bonuses I
know Jay and she's got a strong social
conscience I'll let her indulge her not
for profit in seats you can't run an
organization by motivating everybody
differently and how you harness that but
in the end all leaders think a lot about
how do I motivate my team and my people
to get what I want down or what I
believe needs to be done done motivation
of the team selection is a part of it
appointments is a huge part of it it's a
motivational tee to your point but I
just like to leave this idea of
motivation not inspiration even though I
think inspiration come in incredibly
powerful a motivational technique for
very talented well-intentioned people
not everybody sad is like that
I say some of the most effective leaders
I have seen I don't necessarily like it
and I certainly wouldn't necessary my
dinners with these leaders they are
brilliant at manipulating so just try to
avoid forming judgments on people at
this stage and just talk about what
makes for effective leaders and then the
final point the final characteristic at
least I see it of leaders is that all
leaders all leaders whatever their
sector lead by example they may not
think about it they may not talk about
it they do they do it whenever they say
something or they do something people
notice in organizations people
our bus Watchers it's just a human
instinct to just look up you may not
like what you see but people watch and
they listen and they watch what people
do and they listen to what they say and
they look for the difference and all the
work he lived on has a huge amount of
academic research on this is is that
people they watch and they look and they
listen and then they see what the
differences are and that's what the
example that's example when people get
up and bang on were values we have an
organization we really believe that and
then at the next meeting get beaten up
did you miss your budget by two percent
that's what people notice and it's
exaggerated by the talk people do not
take examples from what they hear they
take the examples what they see and what
they observe in terms of human behavior
so all leaders lead by example some
pressures on that when you are in a
leadership position it means whatever
you say or do becomes an act of
leadership by example but all leaders do
that and the thoughtful ones think about
that all the time one of the best in
fact the best talk I've ever heard on
leadership which covers all the five
points and the non contextual point and
it was an impromptu one it was bad given
it wasn't a speech it was a talk by a
noncommissioned officer a sergeant in
the British Army who'd been in Iraq and
then in Afghanistan he was a private in
Iraq and he become a sergeant
Afghanistan and he talked about
leadership this is from the bottom of
that one and it is the best controlled
experiment he'd worked the five
different officers three of whom he
thought were great and one of whom he
thought was truly terrible he talked
about his own leadership experience and
the one a was an ACCI Mesmer I mean he's
a very bad talker but it was mesmerizing
in terms of content but what he
absolutely was saying was the leadership
by example of what people do
particularly under fire literally under
fire is what you remember just remember
that as well you think about leadership
by example all of you when you leave
here will be watched as leaders and it's
what you do and what you say and the
difference between of two that people
actually notice so let me recap before I
conclude when I talk I've tried to give
you some framing
comments on leadership about it's non
Arkel it's multifaceted in its shape by
context do you think about that and then
I've five thoughts on what I believe
defines what leaders do they set a
direction their niche initiate stuff
they stick with it they think hard about
motivation and they know that they
always lead by example whatever they do
and they say and I think that framework
and we can talk about in the clearin
area I think can hopefully help help to
find what is a good leader now I just
want to conclude and looking at the time
but let me just this is a business
school so I probably should finish with
some tips and suggestions on how you as
individuals can become if you want to
come it can become better or more
effective personal leaders and I think
what I'm going to say is true not just
for your careers I imagine all of you
going into entrepreneur consulting tech
but some of you hope to be gay into
academia or the public so this may be
some of you going to focus on being a
parent and I hope this will be relevant
to all of you every single one of you in
this room about some tips on how you
might become a more effective personal
reader
this will only resonate with you if what
I said the last 20 minutes has if not
look at your factories now it's a good
time to do that the first thing that I
think you can do is spend a bit of time
thinking about the context point I mean
really thinking about it by context I
mean when you join an organization
understand its history is crises its
people its culture its values most of us
spend more of our time complaining about
our context than we do thinking about
them generally great leaders don't
complain very much great leaders
generally don't complain and they don't
blame their thinking they're saying I'm
not gonna do that again but just think
about your context before many of you
will be frustrated by your first jobs
you will be it's just part of it I was
but instead of getting to for us to just
think about it why is it why is it and
often it's a lack of understanding the
context of that organization what are
the goals that are found
one of the goals of this organization
you know what are they trying to do what
are the things that discard them why do
they do something so idiotic if good
people do something idiotic they're
probably not doing something idiotic is
my general observation there's a reason
spend time understanding the context and
I often meet it means spending time
understanding the history the history
either of the founders or the
organization itself so at be tip number
one spend some time on that secondly I'm
really very careful that this is a
Stanford GSB audience on this because
you get a lot of this I know but this
self-awareness stuff is important it is
important you can take it too far I mean
you can spend too much time analyzing
yourself you know when you you you get
caught at dinner talking to somebody's
going to the shrink for last year the
most boring evening I'll ever have in
your life you know you learn more about
people you ever want to know but
nevertheless the self-awareness stuff is
really really important not just how do
you look at yourself now see yourself
that's important too but how do others
see you as a leader it's think about it
I'm a great believer in 360-degree
feedback and feedback from others but
I'm not very impressed by how people use
this feedback they tend to take
criticisms or something they got to deal
with and praise or something they got to
do more of not true not true if you're a
leader and you get it feedback and I saw
this raw Franco sangria you know really
good guy high standards but really tough
ones team's doesn't give credit enough
don't necessarily be less tough on teams
and give more credit if that what makes
you a leader motivates your team maybe
it's the right thing so think about the
feedback or you get great fit lovely
person to work with really sufer always
look to work with him and that's all the
feedback is that's some orange light sir
are you pushing people hard enough or
the quality Sanders half now so when you
get feedback don't just pick the classes
and say oh I must correct the minuses
that is not the way the great leaders
operate they say is that how does that
feedback link to my leadership impact
profile
I'm not saying ignore the criticisms and
you're not saying don't bask in the
glory appraised if you get it but think
about it in terms of so what so what so
that's not tip number two self-awareness
in a leadership context not just as a as
a human being
thirdly leadership skills I think
leadership can be taught a bit I think
it can be learnt a lot and I think it
could be experienced a lot let me talk
about what can be taught and learned
through coaching or through the
classroom or through cut colleagues and
they are usually what I call classic
leadership skills communications would
be one you can learn and practice how to
be a better communicator strategic
planning
it's another team-building is another
there's some leadership skills that you
can develop EQ is another you know there
are some skills so when you get your
feedback if you let's say which skills
can I get taught or can I practice so
think about that there are some other
skills and this is tough for MBA types
and consulting at types I think I would
say this because then you get to my age
you start saying things like this but I
believe it can only be learned through
experience I think it's very very
different maybe through reading and
studying that's really experience and
this is the bugbear of people in a hurry
and these skills are skills like
judgment diplomacy statesmanship
cultural sensitivity it's very very hard
in a classroom setting or a peer group
setting to learn these skills I mean if
I take diplomacy which I think is going
to be an increasingly important
leadership skill in a globalizing
business unless you've been to a lot of
countries made a food of yourself in a
number of different cultures seeing
other people get it right and get it
wrong being and lived in three or four
different places quite hard to get that
sort of learning and that takes time as
I said and that's the enemy of most MBA
training is time but there are some
skills that I just do think that
experience is really important and I
urge you to think
about that because particularly of those
of you whose careers will not get off to
a rocket like start and it will be a
third of you and it would be difficult
for you don't give up on that that could
be the making of you it could be the
making of you and for those of you will
be most of use careers get off to a
rocket buy a start
don't get seduced by that either because
that could be the breaking of you as
well
so just think about the experiential
skills of leadership I think that's a
really really important factor of it so
skills that can be taught think about it
skills that can be that final point
which is not a tip thought but it's a
request it's a request
because I think you know as Stanford
grads or potential grads either you know
in the summer of the summer off I do
think have a bit of an obligation and
one thing I absolutely believe about
leadership is that it can be nurtured it
could be nurtured and this is I think
one of the responsibilities of
leadership is to nurture leadership in
others there are some institutions that
do it really well but most do not they
think about it we think about it in
terms of ourselves so as you get into
positions of influence when you can
actually deal with potential leaders
think about nurturing leadership what do
I mean about that one give people
everyone everyone you work with and I'm
talk about your assistant and talk about
your peers and talking about everyone
give them a leadership opportunity and
that does not mean a bigger model to run
necessarily it doesn't mean a bigger
responsibility or a bigger sorry give
them a leadership opportunity where they
can exercise a different go back to my
five-part framer give them an
opportunity it's amazing the payback you
get and look really great leadership
organizations not the great leadership
leaders the great leadership
organizations are one that really really
focus on giving everyone leadership
opportunities you've got to accept that
some people will not be able to take
those opportunities and some people fail
that's part of it you've got to give
opportunities in a very very thoughtful
way the second one is encouragement
encourage people it's an obvious point
we all all of us like encouragement
anybody says
they don't care about to this line we
all like it but it really does make a
huge different but it only makes a
difference of its that company by
challenge most company is now quite a
lot in the US like this which what I
call great job cultures great job Joe
great job Jane they're not usually very
strong leadership cultures because if
the challenge isn't now and the
standards aren't there the encouragement
can diminish an organization so with
encouragement that comes challenge and
standards and pushback you see this
impairing in particular it's a very
difficult I don't know if we have
anybody as a mom or dad here but that
balance being encouraging your children
and pushing them very very important to
us I believe this is true for
organization this is combination setting
the stand as challenge I ain't
criticizing and encouraging something
for you to think about I think it's
really really something important so if
I could just leave sort of four thoughts
before I shut up and thread open to just
questions think a lot about your context
think about yourselves as leaders not
just in terms of feedback think about
building your skills through teaching
coaching learning reading and through
experience and then finally think about
your obligation to nurture and
leadership in others I will stop that I
have one or two things I said resonate
if not this is your chance to correct me
hi thank you for the talk you know one
of the most interesting just say who
yeah ii yes my name is john john in the
first year here so one of the most
interesting things about business school
husband talks like these where we kind
of learn heuristics about you know what
makes a good leader and you know so
thank you but i had just had a question
about your framework one of the things
that i noticed and you said something
kind of interesting which was that you
shouldn't impose kind of moral judgments
on the decisions that people make in the
way that they decide to motivate other
people and that kind of goes that kind
of goes against a heuristic that i've
learned about leadership which is that
leadership should be should come from a
place of kind of good or ethical morals
or or judgments how do you so how do you
kind of bring those bring those together
because i you know i think i look at the
framework and you know a lot of it is
consistent with kind of people you know
who have political leaders of them to me
for example like that's my question
it's it's it's a great question and if I
implied that there isn't well I don't
believe it there isn't a role for moral
and ethical leadership business and gets
wrong my point was when you look at what
leaders do some of them are not ethical
people are not moral and you should
observe that I think that is not the
sort of leader that any of you many of
you any of you I hope in this room would
ever want to be or would ever want to
work and I wouldn't but the what my
point was that when you're Coburn at the
analyzing leadership you've got to look
at what they do now let me just take an
example I came for an organization which
likes to sad salvan is a values driven
organization a superior way just had to
run like a lot of Johnson & Johnson I
twelve is the values for an organization
and they were very good but the best
what kind of values we have an
organization I've ever read is about
was around the Salomon's trading floor
the 1980s and that was the values driven
organization and those values were
horrible horrible but they were
effective for a time and that was the
point on the time there was no ethic
that you know they had a you eat what
you kill the guy who earns the most
money is the top god there's a gate to
promote it that was that values and my
point was that worked as a leadership
organisation for a bit but it wasn't
sustaining and the real leaders which is
he didn't add an ethical judgment so
what I was trying to say was just look
at what makes this organisation work
then say how am I going to change it and
do I want to be part of it and I
absolutely agree that I would never work
and I have no indians from whatever work
with an organization that doesn't have
good moral ethical principles but
prepare yourself for the fact that there
are some effective leadership
organizations that do not or have
different ethics and morals from what
you have know just leave it at that
thank you thank you so I'm a really
crucial part of leadership or leadership
but don't prejudge until you know what
the context is do it is it ladies first
all right that one and I sure we get the
right hi thanks for coming I'm Omer
first year if someone comes from
organization who seems to value MBAs a
lot or an MBA degree and doesn't have an
MBA himself I was wondering what you
think are the benefits and maybe
setbacks an MBA has I could say having
heard me as non-nba talk you're probably
work better able to judge at the man and
I don't think it matters in a sense I
mean McKinsey is a big MBA I think it
matters
and let me just say why which is not say
I don't think an MBA doesn't matter
saying MBAs incredibly valuable and I'm
a passionate proponent of MBAs by the
way I am of all tertiary education well
let me just say for example I come from
a when I was at McKinsey everybody think
Mackenzie's an MBA school under 50% of
McKinsey people have MBAs under 50% so
we a lot of MBAs more than anybody and
35% now have PhDs so it's not an MBA
sort of I think MBA and the key is the
talent the key is the talent always the
talent the talent the talent and the
truth is that a lot of very motivating
high talented people do MBAs they did I
mean this is just in this room I know I
don't know hardly any of you I just know
there's an awesome amount of talent here
that's why firms like mine are here
primarily it's not I don't want to be
rude deal it is not because you're
standing here and that's point one the
second thing is I think MBAs and also a
JD or bring a medicine or an engineer
adds a discipline and a network in a
social which is irreplaceable I think it
is a replace will you know that and I've
seen that over the weekend saying hey it
adds a lot of a lot of value and thirdly
I think this is less true now than it
was when I was young it teaches you
techniques and skills that you need in
business now I say that because I've
noticed a lot of MBAs now have a
consulting background or being in a
hedge fund or Investment Banking and
they know a lot of stuff where they come
and I would imagine this is a challenge
when I was young you know you just you
know when I drove McKinsey I did not
know what discounted cash flow was it
would have been nice to MBA before I had
to go through that first yeah but who'd
do that so I think for some people and I
hope some of you the technical skills
important the network is important the
chance to have tertiary education get
the discipline is really really valuable
but do I fundamentally think that MBAs
quire MBAs will change you're looking at
hi my name is Vicki Slav and I'm an MBA
one and I spent three years at McKinsey
as a caveat to my question
um one of the things we've been learning
about in strategy classes the difference
between management and leadership
management being setting targets and
helping people meet them and some such
things and leadership is inspiring
others would you characterize the work
that McKinsey does and other consulting
firms as management or leadership
primarily I well I wouldn't recognize
the difference I think it's very
difficult to lead effectively without
managing and it's very differently a
very good manager with it out at some
point leading so to say management what
about is performance an assessment and
how can you do that and not do that and
a motivational so hang is a bit of a
bogus dichotomy personally I'm probably
going exact opposite of what you've been
taught in your classes I think at some
point in a business organization at
least and I'd certainly see this and if
you want to see the truth risk go and
work in the not-for-profit sector or the
social sector where you see leadership
and no management and it's usually a
disaster and complete disaster in
leadership terms so I think leadership
and management inextricably combined at
some point and really good management
organizations always have some
leadership capacity it's it's a long
question I know what you're saying I
think when it comes to consulting I
don't know I think people make a lot of
a lot of faff about consulting and
business I think I'm much much more
senior and in the end what you're trying
to do is you're trying to get stuff to
happen that's what you're trying to do
and you can do it independently or
dependently so I think there's much much
less different which is why a lot of
consultants very seamlessly go and work
for big organizations around renown it's
no big deal so I think that the
difference is between careers are
grossly exaggerated when you're in the
goldfish bowl of an MBA class you know
you'll you're trained to pick on
differences and then magnify them I
would say this is one of those examples
so that's my personal thank you for the
opportunity to hear about your
experiences
put yourself in in New York City
courtroom District Attorney of New York
comes up to you and says do you have any
reason to believe Rajat Gupta is guilty
what would you say I've known Rajat got
to this is in connection with the
Galleon case obviously very distressing
for people at McKinsey and anybody who
knew Rajat I'd known Rashad for many
many years and I liked him a lot and I
seen him do a massive amount of good
things I don't know what happened on the
legal accord I I do not think he is a
bad person I seen him do too many good
things where the stuff happened this is
all I don't know we'll have to see but I
will defend and I do as Raja as a person
at what he did I will defend absolutely
has he done some inappropriate things it
doesn't look very good and that's
obvious hi my name is Josiah fuller I'm
an MBA one thank you for speaking to us
my question has to do with the balance
between kind of for-profit interests and
also social goals I think a lot of us
came to the GSB because we have lofty
social aspirations would have changed
the world but also were hampered by this
desire to establish our self to
establish ourselves professionally and
be successful in our realm as somebody
who's done a really good job of
balancing both but skewed it seems more
in the for-profit sector but then it had
tremendous impact on both any guidelines
recommendations for how we can do that
for the next 10 20 30 years and when it
makes the most sense to could have
jumped into the social realm to have the
most impact well I think you're saying
it I'm not sure I'd like on social
problems again I personally wouldn't
frame it the way that you have I think
if you want to change the world and do
good for the world you can do it through
the private sector or the public sector
or the social sector and on the whole I
think was good more progress on social
problems has come through the private
sector than the not-for-profit sector so
good intentions go back to my leadership
framework good intentions is not the
same thing as impact and when I see the
appalling ways some incompetence in
Africa where I spend a lot time or in
India I would challenge that do not
assume that because you want to be a
hedge fund manager
going to consulting and a banker that
you cannot and are not doing social good
I think is grossly arrogant for people
to say that about and do not assume that
because somebody works for a non-profit
they are really good people who want to
do good do not assume that and I've seen
it and if you are running a big company
or running a successful private equity
firm you build companies you earn a lot
of money you pay a lot of taxes and you
spend time nurturing leadership you're
doing good so don't get trapped by to do
good you've got to be in the social
sector and if you're in private equity
or because you're a bad it's just not
true in my observation
I personally I'm more of a parable of
the talents type of person and I'm very
interested in social problems I believe
that the big problems of the world are
now in the social domain and I think the
social sector has a role to play I think
the private sector is a huge role to
play as well and I think government does
do that's what I'm trying to get at that
work but let me just boil you've two
minutes the parable of the talents and
those of you is that some Christian
religious backgrounds don't know this is
a story about encouraging someone to do
what they're good at and the best
example I know it was a friend of mine
at McKinsey when I was at McKinsey he
was a director in the Italian office
from McKinsey and he was really--it any
look like an Omani model immaculate
suits yellow Porsche you know he sort of
made you sick when you looked at him to
do that and he was a really nice guy too
which made it even worse and and he had
a very very strong social continuin me
so he was always agonizing with guilt he
said have so much money and any and he
said I want to do that and I love my
seat so I love my portion yeah and
you're a lot of us goes through that
dimension and anyway he couldn't stand
anymore and he resigned he said I'm
going to set up I'm gonna go and work
for a charity in Madagascar he had a a
thing about Madagascar he said I'm gonna
go and devote myself to an orphanage in
Madagascar which he used to go to every
summer for his holiday that's what he
did he didn't go decide in England so as
they got very very strong social
conscience but you
if you saw him you'd say a head gee if
ever I saw one
now the point was what do you do with
that and I remember it's this a billion
piece of leadership the the managing
partner in Italy I also knew very well
because this guy talk to me lightly what
you doing outside and I said you seem in
a muddle why didn't take a few weeks off
and think about it wasn't getting
anywhere but the managing partners said
to him he said Leonardo is his name say
Leonardo he said is this the best thing
you can do he said I've watched you and
you are a brilliant consultant and
financier and I don't know if you'd be a
very good orphanage manager why don't
you do what you're good at and give your
money to people who can build an
orphanage and that's what he's done he
stayed at McKinsey he's very happy it's
got two Porsches now and he gives all
his practice Wells and the the orphanage
has 1,400 people now who have the
biggest impact on social Saturday if
you've gone there and being a
well-intentioned
social worker doing great things maybe
feeling good about it and to an impact
now go back to leadership impact what
did he do I think he's had more impact
so I applaud you and encourage you if
your instincts but think hard about how
can you have the most impact on social
problems and in your context of yourself
there's my point so remember the story
of Leonardo and the Porsches and the
Madagascar thank you mr. Davis thank you
very much for coming my name is Peter
pessoa I'm a second year here my
question is more along the lines of the
personal cost and sacrifice is required
to be a great leader and so when you see
these great leaders where have they gone
where has it gone well in managing the
costs and sacrifices of leadership and
where are they done poorly ah this is
that's a great question then we could do
that raised and this is a bit
generational when I was starting off you
know work because by father dominant
it was mostly male-oriented so I this is
a classic by the way I noticed when you
talk about work-life balance and the
pursuit of happiness you get people like
me to come into each day you really want
35 year olds who are wrestling with this
problem to talk to you about how they
coping with it so I'm not saying either
I or my generations about another tip
you get get somebody who's a young
partner of goldman sachs who's got three
kids and a husband who's a corporate
lawyer to come and talk about work-life
balance it's a lot more used to laying
people like me talk about it I have to
say this is my experience but certainly
for entrepreneurs certainly for
entrepreneurs they don't really get the
question they're obsessed work work is
life that thing is their life and their
families are just around that and they
can be have very good families by the
way so I have to say that you do not
want to hear this but it's my
observation the truth is a lot of great
leaders don't really get the question
they're slightly we are slightly
obsessive not a good answer it's just
I'm just giving it as I see it so at
some point and this is particularly true
for entrepreneurs particularly true for
entrepreneurs it's the question is
almost I didn't get what you for those
of you those of us those of you that
really think about trying to juggle the
balls and their B is particularly true
when children come along I think for
most people and it's not just mums by
the way it's true for dance too
that's a really defining thing about how
you gonna make it work I don't have any
I don't know I I just don't know the
answer I've seen so many people go
through this I think in the end sort of
muddling through is not bad money really
helps if you can throw money at the
problem and get a couple of man isn't a
driver it helps then offer it no no it
you just you know just it helps if it
really doesn't help deciding who is
going to take the primary burden doesn't
have to be the the woman is one doesn't
have to be you trying to get in careers
that are more flexible but I think in
the end its segments of one start
muddling through the only thing that I
would say is and I saw a lot of this at
McKinsey particularly with women very
able women who love the firm but
couldn't make it work
is the don't assume because you adopt
for a different work-life balance you'll
suddenly be more fulfilled and the truth
is I mean in a sense all of you all of
us are cursed we're cursed by ability
and ambition and education and you can't
just switch it off you can't just switch
it off and I think in the end you've
just got to decide for yourself a
balance of fulfillment and life and it's
segments of one something but not get
too neurotic about it and you get too
neurotic about it I think the worst
thing you can be there is not fulfilled
if you are trained to be a leader
trained to be a multi-billionaire
trained to be a the best techie in the
world you've got to do what you got to
do and I think most founders adjust of
that if you do what family work-life
balance and it's personal interest you
just go to muddle through it's it's a
very very long answer that's one thing
that does get easy as you get older and
it's much tougher and I remember this
you know when you're 25 or 30 when
you're older you know and you know when
I was elected the managing partner of
McKinsey my wife's watch it before I did
she said this is gonna be a tough six
years and I said that's okay the next
six years could be for you for the one
after the next six years of that will be
for me that's a way of muddling through
and it was and she said you got to do it
and I said and I knew I knew that it's
gonna be gone all I was and she said
that's okay I understand you you've got
to do it and boy am I paying Bank now
she said the trouble is I do know that
when you're 27 you say honey for the
next six years it's going to be it don't
work I know that you you negate you
negotiate in three months chunks when
you're 27 I know that is not very I
think there's no answer I just you've
got to you've just got to recommend my
point about self-awareness you are high
achieving people and if you suppress
that if you suppress that bad things
will happen and you see it we've had
even mom said I gave it all up to look
after my children they're often doing a
lot of other stuff just they're not
working same with men as well so a long
answer I'm basically I don't know just
figure thank you very much
I just do one last question is that our
item and we'll break for lunch
MBA - my question is regarding your
country the UK as you know it's probably
going to go into recession over the
coming few months and then you're all
advising the government what are your
solutions for both the private and the
public sector in order to prevent the UK
from going to recession recession and do
you think it's preventable well
certainly not by me and III think the
next year is downtown is so much is in
the control of the financial markets I
think Europe is gonna have a very very
difficult period my own view is that the
credit crisis in Europe hasn't caused
the current problems they've exposed
them and these problems have been
building over 15 years we sort of knew
it it's now very very clear when you've
had a 15 year problem that's exposed you
do not solve it in two or three years
you know that do you understand them
better than I do about imbalances and
rebalancing and all this recession it'll
be what it will be I think it's gonna be
a lot of a lot of grief in a year over
the next two or three years my view is
that I'm saying in the government look
beyond it and I have nothing to offer
now about how you manage through a
recession fiscal stimulus all the rest
it's very very tricky look beyond it
what are you going to do that will take
it forward then I think you go back to
the fundamentals of productivity
innovation encouraging enterprise all
those sorts of things so the role to any
I'm finding is on productivity
innovation getting into sectors
encouraging the country moving sectors
were off it it's nothing to do the next
two to three years I think that's really
not very the one thing I am working is
on it's civil service reform and public
sector a huge issue in the Western world
is public sector productivity and
productivity leads to growth you know
that I know that most people don't get
it they think the productivity is out
cutting jobs but productivity and growth
are the same thing
fundamentally the Pug that when your
public sector is 50% of GDP which it is
in most
European countries you have to get it as
productive as the private sector and
there's a huge task on that doesn't mean
mean less jobs necessarily I mean if you
take the health sector the productivity
could increase by 30 percent easily and
all those people could be re-employed in
the health sector for greater output so
the thing that I'm focusing on is
productivity in the public sector of
civil service reform using some of the
skills got to be careful it's very
different mindset in the sector and
really get it but public sector
productivity is is going to be huge and
when people say to me my final comment
you know the big biggest problem in the
Western world is greed it's not its
entitlement entitlement is the biggest
single problem we have to capture we
have to challenge that in the public and
in the private sector